tu pourrais juste m'écouter encore une fois
j'écoute tu veux partir en quête
oh ça doit être jeudi je suis sérieux
absolument sûr que ça va marcher
tu es une si bonne année la toison d'
or guérit toute personne vivante ou  chose,
y compris le traitement de Talia, nous guérissons l'
arbre, nous rétablissons la barrière autour du camp,
je suis surpris que vous vouliez l'
accompagner sur ce mr.  sous-vêtement Underwood
quoi que je veux dire, chaque satyre est déjà
parti après la mort de la toison,
je lui en parle, mais c'est un risque que je suis
prêt à prendre pour le bien du camp,
regardez la dernière fois que j'ai entendu dire que la toison d'or
était dans la mer de  des monstres mais les
humains ont appelé le Triangle des Bermudes un
endroit dont un satyre ne devrait pas seulement avoir
peur donc la réponse est non non je suis désolé
Annabelle Annabeth quoi que ce soit c'est une
idée terrible